we've been working on a bipartisan basis
between the
the Treasury Department and members of
Congress trying to come up with
technical approaches at work my standard
is simple it has to work the
restructuring has to be able to take
effect there ought to not be the ability
for holdouts to stop that from taking
effect and that means it has to be a
process where you put an oversight board
you have a restructuring plan and if a
voluntary restructuring doesn't work
there's the ability to require a
restructure of course the devil is
always in the details let's begin with
the holdouts what kind of a cram down
provision would work for you look we
have been clear that if there can be a
voluntary agreement that everyone signs
on to that would be great for the reason
we have bankruptcy rules in general is
that it's really hard to have all
parties agree we've seen what happens
when there's not that kind of required
participation at Argentina look at
Argentina it takes decades to work it
through the court berto Rico doesn't
have decades Porto Rico has a crisis
today
right now today in Puerto Rico you have
hospitals that have laid off hundreds of
workers clothes beds closed wings you
have Zika problem developing without the
funds to come in and prevent the disease
from spreading you have schools that are
closing you have broad economic stress
is leading people to leave the island
almost a hundred thousand people left
Puerto Rico last year let's just be
clear there's three and a half million
American citizens many veterans American
citizens living in Puerto Rico if Puerto
Rico doesn't have a solution that's 39
million Americans were plunged into
chaos that's why the need for action is
so urgent going back to the cram down is
one that's common in corporate
restructurings two-thirds an appropriate
level in your mind I'm not going to get
into the specifics in a conversation
today we have been very clear that we
are
to have a workable approach but it
cannot be an approach where at the end
of the day there is not the ability to
put a restructuring in place there are
different ways to design how voluntary
process dovetails with at the backend
something that is mandatory what I think
this can be resolved I think that there
are a number of issues out there that
are hard issues they're not all equal
some have to be addressed and I've been
clear I was clear in the letter that
treating pensions fairly is one of those
issues we've never said that it should
be treated above all other obligations
but it also can't be treated as if
there's not a need to maintain
retirement payments just think about the
economy of Puerto Rico if you have a
shutdown of retirement income in Puerto
Rico the macroeconomic effects are
terrible for an island that's already
under stress also who's going to keep
working paying into a retirement system
when there are no benefits coming out
it's not
does fair treatment of the pensions
outside of the seniority include a
haircut as we saw Detroit look a lot of
the pensioners have taken a haircut
already so this is not the first round
for many of the
the stakeholders but some people would
say that the current payments are
unsustainable I think that there is a
need to have a sustainable system the
oversight Authority is being set up to
balance the competing demands the
competing you know credit rights the
competing needs to get the economy
moving I think you put in place an
oversight structure that works you have
at the back end or restructuring then
Puerto Rico can get back into a place
where can grow again ultimately all
stakeholders creditors included have an
interest in Puerto Rico's economy
working if the Puerto Rico economy
continues to decline if people continue
to leave they're not going to have money
to pay back creditors at all in some
cases there have been different to the
differences of opinion shall we say who
should sit on the oversight board with
powers it should have the building
requirements for resolutions to move
forward what do you object it I think
that the oversight board has to be one
that is fair that has to balance
interests there are a number of
different approaches that are being
discussed I think that there are
solutions to this that could
if there is in fact as I believe there
is a desire at a bipartisan basis to do
this in a way that's effective we can
find a pathway with how do you keep it
independent enough that board is going
to have to make some awfully tough
decisions it look we've seen oversight
boards like this in the past they do
have an awful lot of authority you know
the truth is Puerto Rico needs to have
sustainable economic future this
oversight authority can help lay the
foundation for that it can do so in a
way that's respectful of the fact that
there is a government in the
Commonwealth that takes has to take the
initiative having that combination of a
local government that takes initiative
with an oversight is a package that can
work as I understand it the oversight
panel would have the power or the
authority to restructure
general-obligation pressing the senior
covina death you know what people say
about that right that's going to destroy
the municipal bond market as we know it
because those are constitutionally
protected payments look I think what we
just would potentially do great harm to
the municipal market is an uncontrolled
chaotic unwinding in Puerto Rico Puerto
Rico's debt has been treated on its own
and different from all of the municipal
that for some time now I don't think
there's any reason to look at the data
that we've seen and see any spillover
is what a chaotic unwinding produces
that is not a path we've ever taken but
if Congress can decide on its own to you
to laterally rewrite the rules around
certain classes of geo bonds why would
anybody want to buy into geo bonds in
the future not I think that they just
don't know i think the
process of bankruptcy is well known to
investors it's not a new issue that in
restructuring
there is a balancing of interest as long
as it's done fairly as long as it is not
a case where you have a one size fits
all and it treats all rights and equal
basis there's a lot of history we're not
in reinventing the wheel here there's a
lot of history to restructure well
except for the fact that you know Puerto
Rico is in a class unto itself it is in
a class Intuit's and what you're
contemplating rewriting the rules for
general obligation bonds is virgin
territory what's to stop Illinois from
seeking the same relief but you know you
just said it yourself it's in a class of
its own
it is not i think the case that states
and territories are the same states have
options available to them than a
territory the governor of illinois would
say what about me i don't think that any
governor would choose to go through what
puerto rico is going to be going through
if this legislation passes this is not
something that any any jurisdiction
would choose if they have other choices
and states have other choices mr.
secretary just yesterday as you know
group of hedge funds agreed to a 44 sent
haircut on nine hundred million dollars
of the government development bank bonds
prepa has a deal with its creditors why
can't this be resolved privately you
know the way it is in SE the UK Europe
they even resulted in Iceland the
problem is that
these agreements are very much one-off
agreements and in the case of
yesterday's agreement as i understand it
it doesn't take effect unless all
creditors agree this is a puzzle that
either gets solved as a whole or it
doesn't get solved it's going to have to
involve comprehensive review and
restructuring and I think it's a mistake
to think that you can do it a little
piece here and a little piece there the
numbers just don't work that way mr.
secretary moving on from Puerto Rico if
we may last week the Treasury Department
put China Japan Korea and Taiwan on a
currency watch what specifically
concerns you about their practices and
policies so this report that we put out
last week is the first report we put out
since the enactment of new requirements
as part of passing trade legislation to
provide new tools for us to really put a
monitoring system in place that has
objective criteria to look at currency
practices I think that you have took the
reason for that legislation the reason
for that legislation is that to help
American workers and businesses expand
and
go into markets internationally what we
need is to have trade agreements that
protect the rights of all parties that
means we have to have high standards in
terms of things like currency practices
this report gives us the ability to make
sure that that's the case we know that
sustained imbalances and trade
imbalances particularly against the US
and intervention on a one-sided regular
basis are issues that give rise to
concern about unfair currency practices
I think it's important that this
monitoring has been in place it's also
important to note that none of the
country's triggered all of the criterias
criterion so this is now something that
is going to be an ongoing monitoring
process mr. secretary the Japanese have
gone further than any other central bank
with unconventional monetary policy the
latest effort negative interest rates
didn't work the yen strengthened and
stocks tanked
given what you've seen and how the
market responded are you perhaps less
concerned about what Japanese might do
to / to great persistent imbalances
among currencies I've been very clear I
think with Japan needs to do is use all
of its policy levers and not really rely
excessively on one lever such as
monetary policy they need to have fiscal
policy that works they need
restructuring structural reform that
works and they've had an aggressive
monetary policy we have not criticized
the monetary policy because it is stayed
within the international agreements as a
member of the g7 and the g20 Japan has
lived by the agreements it's made to
refrain from from competitive
devaluation to refrain from exchange
rate targeting
we've made it clear we think it's
important for all parties to agreements
to continue to live by mr. secretary you
and your department have been very
forceful and decisive when it comes to
curbing tax inversion deals are you
satisfied with the efforts with the
effects excuse me of your latest effort
in that regard and might you be
considering even further action look
I've been clear for several years now
that the only way to really solve the
inversion problem is to do tax reform
fix our tax code and stop shut the door
to inversions once and for all without
legislation we have to use the
administrative tools we have and we've
taken three actions they've had
increasing impact we are continuing to
look at what options we have there might
be what I've been clear I've been clear
we are going to use whatever tools we
have to try and stop something that we
think that's bad for the American
economy and we think it's wrong let's
just remember what an inversion is an
inversion is a company that takes all
the benefits of being in the United
States our workforce our R&D our rule of
law all the investment we make as a
people
saying I'm going to make my home address
overseas to avoid US taxes and not
paying my fair share that shouldn't be
this shouldn't be the way business is
operating mr. secretary you've made it
clear that you're unhappy with the court
ruling that overturned the
too-big-to-fail designation for metlife
the insurance company if your appeal
which the Treasury Department has said
it will make is unsuccessful would you
consider taking it to the Supreme Court
well look at we've already made clear
we're going to appeal I think we have a
very strong case on appeal because I
think if you look at the logic some
things in this decision I think they're
just backwards the idea that you should
have to prove that there's a likelihood
that
l and cause of crisis misses the point
the real risk the real risk is we have
to make sure we see the things that if a
company failed could have that effect
nobody ever saw something like AIG
coming down the pipe nobody would have
predicted that's likely to happen does
the ruling as it stands now mean that
you'll be less likely to designate other
firms is systemically important at least
until the appeal is resolved you know
it's interesting we've had we've only
designated a few firms as non-bank for I
believe and we are using this Authority
in a very careful way each one is
reviewed on the merits it's analytically
driven and there has been this sense
that there's in the wings an enormous
inventory of case is about to be brought
and I've been very clear that's not in
fact the case we are taking these
actions as they're needed and we don't
look to take actions for the sake of
taking action do you expect to name
asset managers is systemically important
given where your review stands we just
about two weeks ago issued an F Sox
statement
asset management concerns it's put in
place some ongoing work that will mostly
increase our trim visibility the
transparency so that we can see whether
there are risks there that require
additional action I think that it was a
very well thought through statement that
we put out and then work is now underway
to implement that but it's premature to
talk about any kind of designations
because what we put in that statement
reflected what we really need right now
which is visibility